and well that's thank you for sharing
number one I think it's really honest
sort of assessment sure it's fascinating
to me because we knew each other before
you were at Facebook before you had
money and you were at AOL I was just so
my company there and we were just too
dorky kids trying to embed probably
shared a lot of DNA both of us you know
didn't have ideal childhoods both of us
just trying to make it their way in the
world and then you got to this point
where you felt like hmm I'm not happy
anymore and why am I trying to impress
these other people what's the core of
that why were you trying to be part of
this like big grand hedge fund world
because you were so good at it you went
to that
what's that conference in New York will
you pick Saira soon no I was on the
stage at this I was the best was we were
running I was running until we shut it
down top 2% hedge fund in the world and
I was doing it an hour a week yeah yeah
I mean it was an enormous amount of
money but I literally spent an hour a
week doing that job and it was a top 2%
hedge won right and you're invited to
speak at the hedge fund of hedge fund
conference and it's intoxicating cuz
you're speaking and I spoke about box
and they show a little ticker and box
literally rips up and it's up like 50
percent from where it was and you think
look at the positive impact I had on all
these employees just by opening my mouth
and blathering on yeah it's a very
intoxicating thing but at the core of it
is why because everybody wants to feel
validated and in the absence of being
able to validate oneself from within you
will seek others to validate you and
what's dangerous about the world of that
we live in which is entrepreneurship and
technology is that it is so in the
bull's eye of everybody else now and
everybody wants to be in it around it on
top of it under it associated with it
funding it being a part of it employed
by it employing I mean all of it is true
and so it's a very intoxicating shiny
object that people want to have around
them and so they will use whatever
devices that they have to co-opt that
and in my case it was a very
practical equation which is these
governments these pension funds these
family offices these very famous
important people have all this money
they're like Jamaa come here blah blah
blah and you start to fall for it and I
fell for it and I fell for it for a long
time and then eventually again the
mythology starts to wane and you realize
you know again I'm sure you've I've had
this oh this investor who I let into my
cap table who I thought was gonna solve
all my problems turns out he's just as
[ __ ] stupid as I am and it turns out
wait a minute if I don't solve this
problem
no one's gonna solve this problem oh
wait a minute this person that I hired
on my team who is supposed to solve all
my problems not so much if I don't help
solve it it's not gonna get so I mean it
all goes back to this fundamental belief
in oneself and it was much easier for me
to have that in in small doses in small
things very difficult for me to have it
in big doses and the things that
mattered until I went back and I fixed
the core toolbox that I used to build
myself up in the morning and that took a
long time and now what is social capital
the partnerships been dropped I it will
be what it always has been you know III
think like look when I read articles and
you see all the negative press and it
was so weird because I'm about to
publish our annual investor letter and
I'll just preview it to you for a second
our returns are bananas okay
I've made more in the last eight years
compared to the S&P then Buffett did in
the first eight years of Berkshire
Buffett did a thousand points of alpha I
did eighteen hundred points of alpha my
returns are double Buffett's and that's
if you and that's not including Bitcoin
Amazon and the Warriors which I did
off-balance-sheet in my own money so
there was nothing to numerically
complain about the job that we were
doing we were doing but I was so empty
because I was like we're not doing the
job that we were supposed to be doing
which was investing in health care
education even in investing the point is
like you need to be there to like
basically take a stand on issues and I
have the bully pulpit to do it we had
the capital to do it but we weren't
doing it in as much
of a way that we should have been
climate change still ripping away
unabated what is anybody doing about it
you know education is eroding at the
seams what does anybody really doing
about it
draw costs through the ceiling the
United States healthcare system worse
and worse and worse every year even
though we spend more and more and more
what does anybody really doing about it
and the answer is not as much as it
needs to be done yeah and so that's not
a conversation of investing or IRR Zoar
blah blah blah it's about ideas and it's
about people and it's about drawing a
line in the sand and doing things and I
was good at that for a while and then I
stopped focusing on it and so what we
are today is an attempt to get back to
where we started and what we should have
always been which is really interesting
ways of solving very difficult problems
that if they are solved matter in the
world a very long-term byproduct of that
will be more capital
I suspect enormous amounts way more than
a traditional investing job will do but
that's a byproduct because when you
measure and quantify the absolute value
of progress it's way more enormous than
measuring the absolute value of
discounted cash flows and that's what
people don't get and they get lost in
all of this stuff and particularly now
when tech is so hot and so interesting
in blah blah blah it's easy to lose
sight of what's really important so we
are permanent capital starting with two
billion of my own money we are investing
as much as we need for as long as we
want into things that are important and
what's great about that is like there's
no lp's there's no decision making that
isn't just about a group of us that are
very technical and product oriented can
ask and answer extremely important
technical questions and then we have an
entire network of people around us that
is wholly different than what they were
partnerships with the Salk Institute
partnerships of MIT partnerships with
Xerox PARC partnerships with 40 postdocs
doing all kinds of really interesting
research in the world so we can learn
from these folks who are really on the
ground selflessly trying to solve
important issues in the world and when
we can translate when we can learn then
we can go off and do interesting things
and
those companies now Jason you know that
we really started in fund 1 are doing
exceptionally well
you know I I used to do this thing every
quarter where I would ask the team hey
guys
tell me all of our company's what you
think the exits will be and I always use
it for two reasons one to validate that
whatever they thought was gonna happen
wasn't and two was who was obvious and
should be fired first because it's very
easy for some numbskull to basically say
oh well this one with the most revenue
is worth the most money right that's
easy but how hard is it for someone to
actually project forward what the real
value of a market and a business should
be and how things should be changed and
manipulated and morphed to max value and
I find that there were a few people who
were consistently really good at it
they're still here you know
and so I'm happy to be around folks that
can actually see the forest from the
trees this way but you know I remember
we put in a few million dollars around
this idea of small-scale satellites and
this entrepreneur she was superb and she
could not get a meeting and what's so
lucky for us is we met her after an
entire you know for cockta process where
all the traditional folks were like no
and we gave her what she needed
etc etc and she is literally off to the
races off to space launching an entire
constellation that'll basically become
like an alternative low-cost version of
the internet mega huge multi
trillion-dollar close to trillion-dollar
companies talk about it they blather on
about it they do [ __ ] keynotes about
it she's done it and she's done it with
three million bucks
that's bananas yeah and so I need to be
around people like her
[Music]